It's 1976. The average annual salary in the U.S. is just over $9,000. There is no internet to entertain us, but Jaws is back in theaters, and afternoon delight is burning up the charts. Nixon has resigned in disgrace, so now Ford is president. The Vietnam War has finally come to a close. And now an ambivalent country is about to celebrate the 200th anniversary of the signing of the Declaration of Independence. All of Washington is trying to get hyped. There's going to be fireworks, a huge celebration on the mall.
那是1976年。美国人的平均年薪刚超过9000美元。当时还没有互联网来娱乐大众，《大白鲨》正在重映，歌曲《下午的愉悦》火遍各大排行榜。尼克松因丑闻辞职，福特成了总统。越南战争终于结束了。而现在，一个心情矛盾的国家正准备庆祝《独立宣言》签署200周年。整个华盛顿都试图为此大肆造势。将会有烟花表演，还有在国家广场举行的大型庆祝活动。
And in the U.S. Capitol building, in the marbled, beautiful statuary hall, there's a big iron safe. Like, picture like a Western where they're robbing a train and there's a safe on one of the cars of the railroad train. And it's this big iron monstrous thing. But it's sort of portable. That kind of a safe. like a 19th century safe. This is historian Jill Lepore. The safe, which is known as the century safe, sometimes called the centennial safe,
在美国国会大厦里，在美丽的大理石雕像大厅里，放着一个巨大的铁保险箱。想象一下就像那种西部片里他们抢劫火车，火车的车厢里放着一个保险箱。就是那种巨大的、怪物般的铁家伙。但它又有点像能搬动的。那种保险箱。就像19世纪的保险箱一样。这是历史学家吉尔·莱波尔。这个被称为世纪保险箱的保险箱，有时也被称为百年保险箱，
was specially built on the occasion 100 years before, not of the bicentennial, but of the centennial, the 100th anniversary, of the signing of the Declaration of Independence. The Century Safe was created in 1876 to mark the country's 100th birthday. The idea was to make a time capsule, to fill the safe with objects. things hand-selected to represent the moment they came from. Those meaningful objects were hidden away inside the safe and the doors were sealed. And written on the doors were instructions to the future.
是100年前为庆祝《独立宣言》签署100周年而专门建造的，这里的100周年不是指双百周年，而是指百年诞辰，即《独立宣言》签署的100周年。世纪保险箱于1876年制造，为了纪念建国100周年。当时的构想是做一个时间胶囊，在保险箱里装满物品。这些物品是精心挑选出来的，用来代表他们所处的那个时代。这些有意义的物品被藏在保险箱里，箱门也被封锁了。门上还写着给未来的指令。
It is inscribed upon it the promise that it will be opened by the President of the United States in the crazy futuristic year of 1976. Good morning to all of you. Happy birthday to the USA. We are very pleased to have you assembled here this morning on a very historic occasion. And President Ford has been coerced by his aides to carve out a few minutes in his schedule to trapes from the White House over to the Capitol building into Statuary Hall, where a fleet of photographers is assembled awaiting this century-long weight. finally coming to an end with the opening of an iron and glass door.
上面刻着一个承诺，它将在疯狂的未来年份1976年由美利坚合众国总统开启。大家早上好。美国生日快乐。我们非常高兴今天早上能在这里欢聚一堂，共同庆祝这个极具历史意义的时刻。福特总统在助手们的劝说下，好不容易从日程中挤出几分钟，从白宫步行来到国会大厦的雕像大厅。在那里，一大群摄影师云集于此，等待着这个历时一个世纪的漫长等待，终于随着一扇铁质和玻璃大门打开而宣告结束。
When the safe was first sealed, there was a record of what had been put inside. But by 1976, after its 100-year journey through time, most people had no idea. And so now they were gathered around with one shared question. What was in there? What objects did those Americans from the past? think would really say, this is who we are. These are the things that represent us and our values. I mean, what a daunting task.
在这个保险箱最初被封存时，里面放了什么东西是有记录的。但到了1976年，经过了跨越时空的100年旅程后，大多数人对此一无所知。所以现在大家聚集在这里，心中都有一个共同的疑问。里面到底有什么？过去那些美国人认为，到底是什么样的物品能够真正代表“这就是我们”？哪些东西能够代表我们以及我们的价值观？我的意思是，这是一个多么艰巨的任务啊。
What a fraught exercise? What objects could anyone possibly pick to tell the story of the country, of our country? What fool would even attempt such a thing? From 99% Invisible and BBC Studios, this is a history of the United States in 100 objects. I'm Roman Mars. Okay, so let's go back 100 years before 1976 when the safe was first being filled, which, to my understanding, was at the World's Fair of 1876. So could you talk about that World's Fair? Yeah, so World's Fair, we don't really have them anymore.
这是一个多么令人揪心的举动？到底能挑选出什么物品来讲述这个国家、我们国家的故事呢？哪个傻瓜会去尝试这种事？这里是由99%隐形和BBC工作室联合出品的《100件物品中的美国史》。我是罗曼·马斯。好吧，让我们回到1976年的100年前，也就是这个保险箱最初被填满的时候，据我了解，那是在1876年的世界博览会上。你能谈谈那届世博会吗？好的，世博会嘛，我们现在已经不怎么办了。
It's a little bit even hard to describe, but it's a little bit like a circus plus Epcot Center plus Disney World plus the UN. It had arts and science exhibits from across the globe. 30,000 exhibits in more than 200 buildings. You could climb a ladder onto the right arm, the torch arm of the future statue of liberty. Alexander Graham Bell demonstrated what turned out to be his prototype of the telephone. Heinz ketchup was introduced to the public. It is hard to conceive of those as contemporary inventions, but with innovation accelerating to light speed, there they were, side by side. The big hit of the Centennial Exposition was Machinery Hall,
甚至有点难以描述，但它有点像马戏团加上艾克赛特中心、迪士尼世界再加上联合国。它汇集了全球各地的艺术和科学展览。在200多座建筑中展出了300万件（注：原文30,000）展品。你可以爬上梯子，去触摸未来自由女神像的右手和火炬手臂。亚历山大·格雷厄姆·贝尔展示了他当时设计出的电话原型。亨氏番茄酱也是在那时被引入公众视野的。很难把这些看作是当代的发明，但随着创新速度呈光速般加速，它们就这样并排出现了。百年博览会的最大轰动是机械大厅，
where there was this giant power engine. There were also typewriters and sewing machines, just like a lot of gadgetry that was fun to see. President Grant personally pulled the lever of that engine that brought all the other exhibits in the hall to live. The technology had advanced so far that for most attendees, it must have seemed like magic. The fair was, in many ways, the centerpiece.
那里有一个巨大的动力发动机。还有打字机和缝纫机，有很多让人觉得好玩的小机械。格兰特总统亲自拉动了那个发动机的闸刀，让大厅里所有的其他展品都运转了起来。技术的发展是如此先进，以至于对大多数参展者来说，这简直就像是魔法。在许多方面，这届世博会成为了
of the nation's first big birthday. So could you give a sense of what the general mood of 1876 is? Are people really feeling like celebrating the United States? Like, what is going on? It is a big commercial hullabaloo to get people to celebrate the United States in 1876. Recall, we're only 11 years from the end of the Civil War, in which three quarters of a million Americans died. We are at the turning point in which reconstruction,
国家首次盛大生日庆典的核心。那么你能谈谈1876年的整体氛围是怎样的吗？人们真的有在庆祝美国的节日吗？当时到底是什么情况？1876年为了让人们庆祝美国，进行了一场大型的商业宣传大吵大闹。回想一下，我们距离南北战争结束仅仅过去了11年，那场战争导致了75万美国人丧生。我们正处于一个转折点，在这个转折点上，重建计划——
the plan for a fully multiracial democracy in the United States for the first time, is just about to be abandoned. And there is a great spirit of reform in the United States still, especially under the banner of the women's suffrage movement. So there's a lot of political tumult in these years. but there is a tremendous amount that Americans who have an appetite for celebration are very keen to celebrate. It may be surprisingly less about American freedom and liberty and democracy and more about American economic and industrial might and geographic expansion. One in five Americans came to the 1876 World's Fair to see all of that innovation for themselves.
即在美国历史上首次建立一个完全多民族民主社会的计划——正面临被放弃的境地。美国国内仍然存在着一股巨大的改革精神，特别是在女性选举权运动的旗帜下。因此，这些年里有着大量的政治动荡。但对于那些有着庆祝热情的美国人来说，依然有大量的事情让他们非常渴望去庆祝。这可能出人意料地少关乎美国的自由、独立和民主，而更多地关乎美国的经济和工业实力以及领土扩张。五分之一的美国人来到了1876年的世博会，亲眼目睹所有这些创新。
In fact, progress had accelerated so much, life was changing so fast that for the first time, Americans were becoming fascinated with the future. You would say now, okay, for all of human time, having humans always been interested in the future, and I would say no. That is, like, people, like, we just live in like, what is the future of work? What is the future of automation? What is the future of AI? What is the future of democracy? Like, all of our political debates are about the future.
事实上，进步的速度太快了，生活变化得太快了，以至于美国人有史以来第一次对未来着迷。你现在可能会说，好吧，在整个人类历史上，人类难道不一直对未来感兴趣吗，而我会说，并不是。也就是说，人们，就像我们现在总是生活在——什么是工作的未来？什么是自动化的未来？什么是人工智能的未来？什么是民主的未来？就像我们所有的政治辩论都是关于未来的一样。
It is like a kind of like Davos-A-Span pipeline of like, we must talk about the future at all time. Nobody thought about the future until the 20th century. So, but there is kind of the beginning of a notion of historical time that is novel in the 19th century. And people can picture rockets and going to the moon and they're not called robots until the 1920s, but you can kind of, there's a lot about mechanical men. So people begin for the first time really thinking like, if machines keep getting better and faster and bigger and stronger, what will the future look like? And it's in this moment of celebrating the past and thinking about the future that one woman, Anna Deem, a magazine publisher, dreams up the Century Safe. She was a Civil War widow. And, you know, it was a canny businesswoman.
这就像是一种达沃斯式的流水线，好像我们必须时刻谈论未来。直到20世纪之前，没有人去思考未来。因此，虽然19世纪产生了一种新颖的历史时间观念的萌芽。人们可以想象火箭和登月，虽然它们在20世纪20年代之前还不叫机器人，但你大概可以想象，有很多关于机械人的讨论。所以人们开始第一次真正地思考：如果机器变得越来越好、越来越快、越来越大、越来越强，未来会是什么样子？正是在这个庆祝过去并思考未来的时刻，一位名叫安娜·迪姆的女杂志出版商构想出了世纪保险箱。她是一位内战寡妇。而且，你知道的，她是一位精明的女商人。
And here was a stunt to get some attention for and sell subscriptions to the magazine in the newspaper. So she commissioned the building of this elaborate safe, which is kind of cool. It has like engraving all over it. And then it promises on it that it's going to be opened by the president of the United States in 1976 on July 4th, which is just cool. It would have been like looking at a rocket ship. So she gets space at the world's fair to set this thing up. And then people interact with it. Like how do they?
这其实是一个用来吸引眼球并为杂志和报纸销售订阅的噱头。于是她委托建造了这个制作精巧的保险箱，这个箱子其实挺酷的。它的全身都有雕刻。上面还承诺它将在1976年7月4日由美利坚合众国总统亲手开启，这真的很酷。当时这感觉就像看着一艘火箭船。于是她在世博会上争取到了一个位置来摆放这个东西。然后人们开始与它互动。他们是怎么互动的呢？
What is on display? Well, the thing itself. But then you could look at what was already in there. And you could pay money to have. yourself put in. You could pay to have to sign your autograph in an autograph book of just anybody. And these chumps did that. It was a clever ruse. Give me a kid. You got a nickel. So she made a little pretty penny.
有什么展出内容吗？嗯，就是这个东西本身。然后你可以看看里面已经有什么了。你还可以花钱把你自己放进去。你可以花钱在一个签名簿上签下你的名字，哪怕你只是个普通人。而这些傻瓜真的这么做了。这是一个聪明的骗局。给我一个孩子。你有个硬币。所以她赚了一小笔钱。
So like if the idea of time capsules is quite new and the idea of like thinking about the past is actually a new concept. Thinking about the future is kind of a new concept. How does she convince people to care about this enough to get floor space on the World's Fair? I think she was a great show business woman. And it did speak to the moment in the sense of it was a clever idea, right?
如果说时间胶囊的概念相当新颖，思考过去的理念其实也是一个新概念。思考未来在某种程度上也是一个新概念。她是怎么说服人们足够关心这件事，从而在世博会上获得场地空间的呢？我想她是一位出色的商业演出女性。这确实契合了当时的时代背景，因为这是一个聪明的想法，对吧？
Here we are 100 years from the Declaration of Independence. Why don't we think about where the country will be 100 years from now? After the fair, having done everything she could to drum up excitement, Anna sealed her safe full of objects and entrusted it to Congress. And it goes down, you know, into the Raiders of the Lost Ark storage facility. So, like, really over the course of this hundred years, despite the ornate bigness of the safe itself, it really does get kind of forgotten. Yeah, it's meant to be forgotten for a century. Like, what are you going to do? Check on it?
我们现在距离《独立宣言》发表已经100年了。为什么我们不考虑一下从现在起100年后国家会变成什么样呢？世博会结束后，安娜为了激起人们的兴奋做了她能做的一切，她把装满物品的保险箱封好，并将其托付给国会。然后它就被送到了，你知道的，类似于《夺宝奇兵》的那个储藏设施里。所以，在这100年的时间里，尽管保险箱本身装饰精美且体型庞大，但它真的被渐渐遗忘了。是的，它就是注定要被遗忘一个世纪的。不然你还能怎么办？去检查它吗？
Yeah, I guess that's true. What is it, what's the point of seeing what it's look like at 1929? So the safe sat in the nation's capital as the country changed around it. It sat there as debates about segregation grew from reconstruction. As the Washington Monument went up and eventually Lincoln's, as men in uniform filled the streets on the way to World War I, then World War II, it sat not bothering anyone through the Great Depression, and wounded knee in the Titanic, in the creation of television,
是的，我想也是。那有什么意义，看看它在1929年是什么样子有什么意义呢？于是，随着国家在周围发生变化，这个保险箱一直静静地呆在国家的首都。当从重建中滋生出的有关种族隔离的争论愈演愈烈时，它静静地呆在那里。当华盛顿纪念碑拔地而起，接着是林肯纪念堂时，当身穿制服的人们涌上街头走向第一次世界大战、然后是第二次世界大战时，它静静地呆在那里，在大萧条、伤膝河事件、泰坦尼克号沉没、电视的诞生过程中没有打扰任何人，
and the Korean War, and the March on Washington, and the Stonewall riots, and men walking on the moon. Time went on and on, and the country changed and changed, and suddenly, it was the 1970s. Yeah, so a newspaper article appears, I think, in 1971, there's a lot of newspaper coverage of the bicentennial, and there's a story about, hey, aren't we supposed to be opening up the Centennial Safe?
还有朝鲜战争、向华盛顿进军、石墙骚乱以及人类登月。时间一天天过去，国家沧海桑田，转眼间，就到了20世纪70年代。是的，所以一篇报纸文章出现了，我想是在1971年，当时有很多关于双百周年的报纸报道，其中有一篇报道说，嘿，我们不是应该打开那个百年保险箱吗？
Because some clever reporter got the idea to go back and see what happened at the Centennial. And then they go to the Smithsonian this moment. And they say, yeah, I think we still have that, but we don't know how to open it. The New York Times runs an article, quote, Smithsonian can't find keys to Centennial Safe. That's right. In the intervening decades, they had lost the key. And then a man in Florida sees the article and realizes he has it.
因为某个聪明的记者萌生了回去看看百年庆典上发生了什么的想法。然后他们在这个时候去了史密森尼学会。他们说，是的，我想我们还保留着那个东西，但我们不知道怎么打开它。《纽约时报》刊登了一篇文章，大意是“史密森尼学会找不到百年保险箱的钥匙”。没错。在随后的几十年里，他们把钥匙弄丢了。然后佛罗里达州的一个人看到了这篇文章，意识到钥匙在他手里。
Because Anadim didn't have any children. And so what happened to the key? And she didn't somehow, for some reason, she didn't get to the Smithsonian. She gave it to her, like, great niece, Edith or something. And this guy in Florida was Edith's, I don't know, great-grandson. I have great-a-a-a-a-a-a-a-a. Is that sound right? Emma, Edith, Gertrude, we could just make up a name that belonged to the Edwardian era, Roman, and we would be covered.
因为安迪姆没有孩子。那么钥匙怎么会到别人手里呢？而且她不知怎么的，由于某种原因，她没有把它交给史密森尼学会。她把它交给了她的，比如，侄孙女伊迪丝还是什么人。而佛罗里达州的这个人是伊迪丝的，我不知道，曾曾孙。我有曾曾曾曾曾曾曾曾……这样对吗？艾玛、伊迪丝、格特鲁德，我们随便编一个爱德华时代的女性名字，罗曼，我们就糊弄过去了。
It was the guy's great-a-a-a-grate-past on the key. So the safe could now be opened. And so then there's a whole rigum-role. of like, are they going to get it out? Are they going to bring it to the Capitol? Then they manage to find it in storage. They bring it to the Capitol. In January of 1976, they have gotten the key from that guy, but maybe it's rusted. They have to hire a locksmith to Jimmy the thing. Okay. So we have at least some of the parts here all coming together in 1976. And again, I kind of was hoping if you could sort of characterize, you know, the national mood at this moment as opposed to 1860s.
这把钥匙就在这个人的曾曾曾祖父那里。所以这个保险箱现在可以打开了。于是接下来的过程就变得非常繁琐。比如，他们能把它拿出来吗？他们会把它运到国会大厦吗？然后他们设法在仓库里找到了它。他们把它运到了国会大厦。在1976年1月，他们从那个人手里拿到了钥匙，但也许钥匙生锈了。他们不得不雇一个锁匠来撬开这玩意儿。好吧。所以我们在这里至少把一些线索在1976年汇聚到了一起。再次，我本来希望你能描述一下，你知道的，此时此刻的全国情绪，与1860年代相比——
76. I mean, this is the bicentennial. Again, it's really tumultuous time. Watergate has happened, like a real change in the sense of what people feel about their government. What is the temperature around the country? And how is the bicentennial unfolding? Yeah, so we're barely out of the Vietnam War. Pentagon Papers, Watergate, Nixon's resigned. In 74, Ford very controversially pardons him. And for Ford, really throwing himself into the hoopla of the bicentennial is about healing the country from those divisions and those wounds. And he comes to really believe that that is his main task as president. It was also controversial because, you know, the country's vision of itself was not a unitary vision anymore
76年。我的意思是，这是双百周年。再次强调，这是一个非常动荡的时期。水门事件已经发生了，人们对政府看法的感受发生了真正的改变。全国各地的气氛如何？双百周年庆典又是如何展开的？是的，所以我们才刚刚摆脱越南战争。五角大楼文件、水门事件、尼克松辞职。在74年，福特在极大争议中赦免了他。对福特来说，真正投入到双百周年的喧嚣中，是为了治愈国家的这些分裂和创伤。他开始真正相信，这是他作为总统的主要任务。这也引发了争议，因为，你知道的，国家对自身的愿景不再是一个单一的愿景了，
than was at any other point in American history. But, you know, there, Jesse Jackson called for a boycott of the bicentennial. Gil Scott Heron wrote this great. piece called Bicentennial Blues. There was a lot of kind of like Frederick Douglass vibe, resistance to the Bicentennial. There were a lot of protests by Native nations, really effective protests. But there were also a lot of powwows, like a lot of public celebrations of Native culture and native politics. So it kind of had it all, the Bicentennial.
就像美国历史上的任何其他时期一样。但是，你知道的，杰西·杰克逊呼吁抵制双百周年。吉尔·斯科特·赫伦写了一首很棒的作品，名叫《双百周年蓝调》。当时有很多类似弗雷德里克·道格拉斯风格的反抗双百周年的情绪。土著民族举行了许多抗议活动，非常有效的抗议活动。但也有许多传统聚会，比如对土著文化和土著政治的大量公开庆祝活动。所以双百周年可以说是包罗万象。
It is with high honor and deep personal pleasure that I introduced the President. of the United States. And so, like, in an effort to grab onto something that we can all rally behind, let's get to this opening ceremony where Ford is in his three-piece suit. Obviously, I'm deeply honored to have the opportunity to open this historic centennial state. Ford stands in front of a packed room, cameras flashing, reading his speech from index cards. It contains many items of interest to us today as we celebrate the completion of our second century. And I think it's actually quite a special, like, I think it's a nice speech, right?
我怀着崇高的敬意和深深的个人喜悦，向大家介绍美利坚合众国总统。所以，为了抓住某种我们都能团结在其背后的东西，让我们来到这个开幕式上。福特穿着他的三件套西装。显然，我非常荣幸有机会打开这个具有历史意义的百年保险箱。福特站在挤满人的房间里，闪光灯闪烁，照着索引卡朗读他的演讲词。当我们庆祝第二个世纪的完成时，它包含了许多今天对我们有吸引力的物品。而且我认为这实际上是一个非常特别的演讲，就像，我认为这是一篇很好的演讲，对吧？
I don't know, I guess if you don't like Ford, you're not, I mean, I kind of like Ford. He just kind of runs with the metaphor, right? As we look inside this safe, let us look inside ourselves. What does this safe contain? It contains our hopes and aspirations as a people. And nothing is more precious than that. America's wealth is not a. material objects, but in our great heritage, our freedoms, and our belief in ourselves.
我不知道，我想如果你不喜欢福特，你可能不会，我的意思是，我挺喜欢福特的。他只是顺着这个隐喻说下去，对吧？当我们向这个保险箱内部看去时，让我们审视一下我们的内心。这个保险箱里有什么？它包含了我们作为一个民族的希望和抱负。没有什么比这更珍贵了。美国的财富不是物质对象，而在于我们伟大的传统、我们的自由以及我们对自身的信仰。
Let us look into our hearts. Let us look into our hearts and into our hopes. Thank you very much. And now let's open the doors. So we're finally at this moment where the safe is going to be open, and we're going to find out what's inside. So Ford finishes his nice little speech. And can you Tell us what happens as they start pulling out some of the items. Yeah. So he pulls things out one by one and sort of looks at them. Here is a... And tries to, like, identify him.
让我们审视我们的内心。让我们审视我们的内心和我们的希望。非常感谢大家。现在让我们打开箱门吧。所以我们终于迎来了这个时刻，保险箱将被打开，我们将发现里面有什么。福特结束了他那番精彩的小演讲。你能告诉我们，当他们开始拿出其中一些物品时发生了什么吗？好的。所以他一件一件地把东西拿出来端详。这是一个……并试着，比如，辨认它们。
That's a Tiffany inkstand, I understand. Like, okay, this is an ink stand. It looks a little different than the ones we have, Kyle. There's a room of photographers and reporters who are awaiting, you know, message in a bottle. confessions of Jefferson Davis, an unpublished memoir that explains the abandonment of reconstruction, like, all the things that I want to see. This is a photograph of an early statesman. I don't see his name. But, I mean, really, it's a dud.
据我了解，这是一个蒂芙尼墨水台。好吧，这是一个墨水台。看起来和我们现在的有点不同，凯尔。房间里有一群摄影师和记者，他们正等待着，你知道的，瓶中信。杰斐逊·戴维斯的供词，一份解释放弃重建的未发表回忆录，就像所有我想看的东西一样。这是一张早期政治家的照片。我没看到他的名字。但是，说实话，这真是一场空欢喜。
Lundy, I have a picture of a chairperson. I don't have any indication of her name, but looks mighty pretty. Like it's just, they're just nothing, it's just like nothing after nothing. And so he pulls out more things and people just start laughing. I guess the other picture was Mr. M. F. Cooper, electoral commissioner. They always seem to get their picture in there, I'm glad. You have very high expectations for, like, what could you want to have seen from 1876? And nothing in there.
兰迪，我有一张某位主席的照片。我没有任何关于她名字的暗示，但看起来非常漂亮。这感觉就像，它们什么都不是，就像一个接一个的虚无。所以他拿出了更多的东西，人们开始笑了。我想另一张照片是选举专员M.F.库珀先生。他们的照片好像总能放进去，我很高兴。你对你从1876年希望能看到的东西抱有非常高的期望。然而里面没有任何东西
there is anything that you would ever have wanted anybody to keep on any occasion. In the end, the safe turned out to have a lot of photographs. Abraham Lincoln was there, Ulysses S. Grant. There was one of all the members of the 44th Congress, the one seated in 1876, and one of Anna Deem herself. And then there's the temperance pamphlet. There is this ink stand that supposedly was Henry Wadsworth Longfellows. There was a book with the names of the 80,000 people working for the,
是你会在任何场合都希望任何人保留的。最后，这个保险箱里有很多照片。亚伯拉罕·林肯在里面，还有尤利西斯·S·格兰特。其中一张是第44届国会所有成员的照片，也就是1876年就职的那届，还有一张安娜·迪姆本人的照片。然后还有禁酒宣传册。有一个据说是亨利·沃兹沃思·朗费罗的墨水台。有一本书记录了1876年为
the government in 1876. There was a picture of Anadine's family physician. He must have been a fantastic doctor and a book of autographs from legislators, clergymen, poets, scientists, and anyone who paid to sign it. Like forgotten nobody's, they might have well been called. Like everyone's just like, oh, okay. Yeah. What are we doing tomorrow? I hate to make this announcement, but the bells have rung in the house for a vote. This is like it's a non-event. So why do you think these objects were so disappointing? I think they don't cross the valley of time with their significance intact.
政府工作的8万人的名字。有一张安娜·迪姆家庭医生的照片。他一定是个了不起的医生，还有一本汇集了来自立法者、神职人员、诗人、科学家以及任何花钱签名的人的签名字帖。就像被遗忘的小人物一样，它们完全可以这么命名。就像每个人都在想，哦，好吧。明天我们要做什么？我很遗憾地宣布，众议院已经为投票敲响了钟声。这就像是一个毫无意义的事件。所以你认为为什么这些物品如此令人失望？我认为它们没有跨越时间的峡谷而完好地保持其重要性。
So what was significant to the people who put them in there was the novelty of photography, the possibility of preservation, I mean, it is kind of new to be keeping something preserved. Yeah. Right? And this would have been a very well-preserved set of materials because they're sealed in a glass box. That would have seemed significant to them,
所以对把它们放进去的人来说很重要的东西，是摄影的新奇感，是保存的可能性，我的意思是，保存东西确实算是一种新鲜事。是的。对吧？而且这一套材料会被保存得非常好，因为它们被密封在一个玻璃盒子里。这在他们看来一定意义重大，
the very fact of being able to seal it. Yeah. You know, embalming was really new in the Civil War because, you know, your son or your brother, your father, died far from home, and people could pay to have the body in bond so that it could be sent by railroad to go home, and you could still, it would still be something you could view before burial. Yeah. And that form of preservation, preserving the human body long enough for a railroad journey
仅仅是能够把它密封起来这一点。是的。你知道的，防腐处理在内战期间确实是新鲜事物，因为，你知道的，你的儿子、你的兄弟、你的父亲死在离家很远的地方，人们可以花钱对尸体进行防腐处理，这样就可以通过铁路运回家，你仍然可以，在下葬之前还能见它最后一面。是的。而那种防腐形式，将人体保存足够长的时间以进行铁路旅行
to get home and be seen by loved ones, was a hugely significant thing, like photography, where you could still see someone who had died. Yeah. And the Century Safe is like, has that sense of embalming a moment in time. But it's more fascinated with the very act of preservation than it is with carefully thinking about what's worth preserving. Yeah. It's almost like a monument to the possibility that we could preserve something where like as a, like what to put in there was an afterthought. thought. Yeah. So what would have been interesting? What could she put in there that you as a historian, and you particularly as like an archive nut as the type of historian who likes old dusty things to pull out? Like what would you have liked to have seen? Oh, something totally sneaky. First of all, nothing published. Nothing that is not handwritten or hand drawn. Like something that is one of a kind that exists nowhere else.
运回家中并被亲人瞻仰，是一件极其重大的事情，就像摄影一样，你可以看到已经死去的人。是的。而世纪保险箱就像是那种将一个时刻进行防腐处理的东西。但它对保存行为本身的迷恋，超过了对仔细思考什么东西值得保存的关注。是的。这几乎就像是一个纪念碑，纪念我们可以保存某物的可能性，而至于放什么进去倒成了事后的想法。是的。那么，什么才是有趣的呢？她可以把什么放进去，作为历史学家的你，特别是作为一个喜欢把旧的、满是灰尘的东西抽出来看的档案狂热者的你？你希望看到什么？哦，绝对是一些偷偷摸摸的东西。首先，不要任何出版物。不要任何非手写或手绘的东西。就像那些独一无二的、在别处不存在的、
that can be found nowhere else, that would be a revelation upon its discovery. So love letters of Ulysses S. Grant. I don't know. You know, like, I don't really care about Ulysses S. Grant, but the diary of a Chinese railroad worker who was learning English or something. Like, something that we don't have and that we were not, that was not going to survive otherwise. I very much take Jill's point here. I can't imagine how disappointing everything in the safe must have felt after 100 years of buildup. But I will say, even those objects that seem like they are absolutely worthless
在别处找不到的东西，一旦被发现就会成为一个启示。比如尤利西斯·S·格兰特的情书。我不知道。你知道的，我其实并不在乎尤利西斯·S·格兰特，但如果是一个正在学英语的中国铁路工人的日记什么的。就像，一些我们没有的、如果不这样做就无法幸存下来的东西。我非常赞同吉尔的这个观点。我无法想象，在经过100年的铺垫之后，保险箱里的所有东西该有多么令人失望。但我必须说，即使是那些看起来完全一文不值的物品，
when you spend a little bit of time with them, they do take you somewhere. Like the Temperance pamphlet. Of course, a handwritten original item would be more profound, but this mass-printed pamphlet represents one of the biggest social movements at the time, one that would ultimately amend the Constitution, not once, but twice. This fight over alcohol that is so far in the past for us was front of mind for them. Or that photograph of the 44th Congress. It features eight black members, more than ever before.
当你花一点时间去了解它们时，它们确实能带你去到某些地方。就像那本禁酒宣传册。当然，手写的原创物品会更有深意，但这份批量印刷的小册子代表了当时最大的社会运动之一，一个最终修改了宪法、而且不仅修改了一次而是两次的运动。这场关于酒精的斗争对我们来说已经十分遥远，但对他们来说却是当务之急。或者第44届国会的照片。它展现了八位黑人议员，比以往任何时候都多。
But it was also the last time we would have so many black representatives for almost 100 years. Were they thinking at this moment in 1876 that this progress would continue? Or could they feel the failure of reconstruction on the horizon? Even that thoroughly unremarkable inkwell that Ford pulled from the safe. It belonged to Henry Wadsworth Longfellow, the celebrated poet and author of Paul Revere's Ride. He's the reason every American knows the redcoats are coming. The version of the Revolutionary War most people carry around. in their heads came from his pen.
但这也是近100年来我们拥有如此多黑人代表的最后一次。他们在1876年的这个时刻是在思考这种进步会继续下去吗？还是他们能感受到重建失败的阴影已经在天边浮现？甚至连福特从保险箱里拿出来的那个完全平淡无奇的墨水瓶也是如此。它属于亨利·沃兹沃思·朗费罗，著名的诗人和《保罗·里维尔的骑行》的作者。正是他让每个美国人都知道红衫军要来了。大多数人心目中对美国独立战争的那个版本，
But when the safe was filled, he was still deep in mourning from the death of his wife. She was at home with him when her dress caught fire, and when Longfellow tried to smother the flames, he suffered severe burns to his face. From then on, he wore a long beard to hide his scars. He was never the same. One writer said his poems about mourning effectively turned him into the nation's grief counselor. And the only reason I know all this is because that inkwell was in the Century Safe. So I understand the disappointment of Joe Lippor and President Ford and the entire population of the United States in 1976.
都是出自他的笔下。但当保险箱被填满时，他正沉浸在妻子去世的巨大悲痛之中。当时妻子正和他在家里，裙子不小心着了火，当朗费罗试图扑灭火焰时，他的脸部严重烧伤。从那以后，他留起了长长的胡子来掩盖伤疤。他再也不是原来的那个他了。一位作家说，他关于哀悼的诗实际上把他变成了这个国家的悲伤辅导员。我之所以知道这一切，全是因为那个墨水瓶在世纪保险箱里。所以我完全理解吉尔·莱波尔、福特总统以及1976年全体美国人民的失望。
But I do think that in all these objects, in any American object, you can find America. The reason why I want to talk to you about this, about the Century Safe, is because we're embarking on this series called. a history of the U.S. in 100 objects. And so we're kind of picking things out, you know, to represent the United States. And I was just wondering, like, should we even be trying to do this? Like, do you have some advice? I don't know. Why not? I say, I say, I'm glad you're doing it. You will have fun.
但我确实认为，在所有这些物品中，在任何美式物品中，你都能发现美国。我想和你谈谈这个的原因，关于世纪保险箱，是因为我们要开启一个名为“100件物品中的美国史”的系列节目。所以我们正在挑选一些东西，你知道的，来代表美国。我只是在想，我们甚至应该尝试这样做吗？你有什么建议吗？我不知道。为什么不呢？我说，我说，我很高兴你们在做这件事。你们会玩得很开心的。
I think that, I think it is important to recognize that much like the present, the past is largely a chronicle of misery. I mean, people suffer. And the people who suffer the most leave the least evidence behind. And so any history that begins with what survives has a real challenge to arriving at any proper perspective on the human condition. I think that is the asymmetry of the historical record, right? People who were wealthiest and most literate and had the greatest resource, not only made a lot of records,
我认为，认识到与现在很相似的是，过去在很大程度上是一部苦难编年史，这一点很重要。我的意思是，人们在受苦。而那些受苦最深的人留下的证据最少。因此，任何从幸存事物开始的历史，在对人类状况得出任何正确的视角时，都面临着真正的挑战。我认为这就是历史记录的不对称性，对吧？那些最富有、受教育程度最高、拥有最多资源的人，不仅留下了大量的记录，
they managed to have their records preserved. And everyone else disappears and just vanishes. Their remains are gone. And I think it puts a special obligation in anyone who's trying to write history or tell a story about the past to be attentive,
他们还设法让自己的记录保存了下来。而其他人则逐渐消失并彻底隐匿。他们的遗迹荡然无存。我认为这给任何试图书写历史或讲述过去故事的人赋予了一种特殊的责任，要保持关注，
to not give up in the face of the asymmetry and to try to repair the historical record. by finding other kinds of evidence, the evidence that does survive, that makes sure that we understand the lives both of the powerful and the powerless. But I wouldn't fall into the notion that it is that you're assembling an exquisite
不要在不对称性面前放弃，而是要试图通过寻找其他类型的证据来修复历史记录，也就是那些确实幸存下来的证据，以确保我们既能理解权贵们的生活，也能理解无权无势者的生活。但我不会陷入这样一种观念，即你是在组建一个精致且具有代表性的档案库。我们并不是在制作官方档案。它可能不会那么精致。但我们将通过物品来讲述我们的故事，讲述美国的故事。准确地说，是100件物品。我们将试图超越官方记录，在那些我们已经想到的要保存并放入博物馆玻璃柜的物品之外寻找答案。
and representative archive. We are not making an official archive. It probably won't be exquisite. But we are going to tell our story, the story of the United States through objects. 100 objects, to be exact. We are going to try to look beyond the official record, outside of the things we've already thought to preserve
相反，我们将与历史学家、作家、故事讲述者以及普通人谈论被丢弃的物品、小型的个人纪念品以及各种各样的东西，它们是如此寻常，以至于我们甚至不会去想它们到底有多重要。我们将看看这些类型的物品能向我们讲述关于我们作为一个国家所走过历程的什么故事。好的与坏的、承诺与失败。
and put behind museum glass. Instead, we're going to talk to historians and writers and storytellers and just normal people about discarded objects and small personal keepsakes and all kinds of things that are so common we don't think about how important they really are. We're going to see what stories those kinds of objects have to tell us about where we've been as a country. The good and the bad, the promises, and the failures.
吉尔·莱波尔，非常感谢你与我交谈。我真的度过了一段美好的时光。不，我也度过了一段美好的时光。我迫不及待地想看看你们在自己的保险箱里放了什么。无论我们在保险箱里放了什么，它都不会是一个面向未来的时间胶囊。这是一个属于当下的收藏，一个对过去的持续更新的每周展览，帮助我们理解这个时刻。我们需要你的参与。
Joe L'Lifor, thank you so much for talking with me. I really had a great time. No, I had a great time, too. I can't wait to see what you guys put in your safe. Whatever we put in our safe, it won't be a time capsule for the future. This is a collection for right now, an ongoing weekly exhibit of the past, to help us understand this moment. And we need you.
我希望你们翻翻你们的阁楼，回想一下你们的家族史，告诉我们你们认为哪些物品能够讲述更宏大的美国故事。给我们发电子邮件至 100objects@99PI.org。我们需要我们这些被遗忘的小人物齐心协力才能把这件事做好。加入我们，和我们一起创造历史。早在2010年，BBC就推出过一个版本的节目，专注于全球，
I want you to look in your addicts and think back through your family histories and tell us what objects you think tell a bigger story of America. Email us at 100 Objects at 99PI.org. It's going to take all of us forgotten nobodies to do this right. Join us as we make history. There was a version of the show back in 2010 from the BBC that was focused on the world,
即《100件物品中的世界史》。所有的故事都来自大英博物馆收藏的物品。我很喜欢它。这是一档具有里程碑意义的节目。所以我很自豪能与BBC工作室合作推出这个全新且重新构想的版本，接过火炬，讲述关于美国的故事。我们每周五都会为您带来新节目，就在99%隐形节目源里。
a history of the world in 100 objects. The stories all came from objects housed in the British Museum. And I loved it. It was a landmark show. So I'm proud to be working with BBC Studios on this new and reimagined version, picking up the mantle and telling stories about the USA. We'll be bringing you new episodes every Friday, right here in the 99% of visible fee.
我们的下一集将在下周五播出，但如果你想提前一周收听该集及所有未来剧集，请订阅 Sirius XM 节目 Plus。我的嘉宾吉尔·莱波尔是一位历史学家，哈佛大学美国历史教授，哈佛法学院法学教授。她还是《纽约客》的特约撰稿人，也是普利策奖的新晋得主。
Our next episode will air next Friday, but if you want to hear that episode and all future episodes one week early, subscribe to Serious XM Podcast Plus. My guest, Jill Lopour, is a historian, Professor of American History at Harvard University, and Professor of Law at Harvard Law School. She's also a staff writer at the New Yorker and a brand new recipient of the Pulitzer Prize.
我喜欢她的每一本书，但她那本精彩绝伦的书《这些真理：美国史》的千禧纪念版刚刚出版。这本书太棒了，伙计们。你们一定要读读它。《100件物品中的美国史》是 99%隐形与BBC工作室联合制作的节目。
I love every single one of her books, but the Jubilee edition of her amazing book, These Truths, The History of the United States, was just released. It's so good, guys. You got to read it. A History of the United States and 100 Objects is a production of 99% Invisible and BBC Studios.
本节目由我罗曼·马斯主持并策划。我们的系列制作人是普里西拉·阿拉比、布伦娜·达尔多夫和埃利·莱特福特。我们的副制作人是艾萨克·费舍尔。本系列由安妮·布朗和考特尼·哈雷尔剪辑，查理·布兰登·金混音。事实核查由艾米·布雷肯完成。我们的主题曲由斯旺·雷尔创作。来自99%隐形，我们的执行制作人是凯西·图。
It's hosted and curated by me, Roman Mars. Our series producers are Priscilla Alawbee, Brenna Daldorf, and Ellie Lightfoot. Our associate producer is Isaac Fisher. This series was edited by Annie Brown and Courtney Harrell, mixing by Charlie Brandon King. Fact-checking by Amy Bracken. Our theme song is by Swan Real. From 99% Invisible, our executive producer is Kathy 2.
来自BBC工作室，我们的执行制作人是安妮·布朗和考特尼·哈雷尔。我们的制作协调员是尚·帕莱，制作经理是梅贝尔·芬尼根·赖特。插图由斯特凡·劳伦斯绘制。99%隐形是 Sirius XM 播客家族的一部分，总部位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的市区。BBC工作室的总部位于伦敦西部美丽的白城。如果你想取得联系或有物品让我们考虑，请给我们发电子邮件至 100objects@99PI.org。感谢卡尔·阿尔伯特中心档案馆的朱利安·P·坎特收藏馆和杰拉尔德·
from BBC Studios, our executive producers are Annie Brown and Courtney Harrell. Our production coordinator is Shan Palais, and the production manager is Mabel Finnegan Wright. Artwork by Stefan Lawrence. 99% Invisible is part of the Serious XM podcast family, headquartered in Beautiful, Uptown, Oakland, California. And BBC Studios is headquartered in Beautiful, White City, West London. If you want to get in touch or have an object for us to consider, email. us at 100 objects at 99PI.org. Thank you to the Julian P. Canter Collection at the Carl Albert Center Archives and the Gerald
福特总统图书馆授权使用开启世纪保险箱的音频。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。
Ford Presidential Library for use of the audio of the opening of the Century Safe. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
福特总统图书馆提供的世纪保险箱开箱音频。本集目前尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。